foreign
[Music]
the following in-game 4K capture has
been edited for time a Ubisoft original
a sprawling 9th century Baghdad appears
in Golden sunlight quick moments flash
by including scenes of battle dramatic
leaps and intense hand-to-hand comments
bus him perches on a horizontal beam
jutting out above a bustling Street
he jumps to a railing across a balcony
and swings on a pole making his way onto
a rope spanning two buildings there you
are he drops and assassinates a man
playing Buzz him knocked down some
wooden scaffolding to block pursuers
keeps acrobatically from
he climbs to a rooftop Terrace then
jumps down to a rope and runs across it
bounding from one beam to another Buzz
him scrambles across the lattice swings
on a pole then grabs a rope and slides
along it like a zip line
figure fires an arrow at him way the
arrow misses and he drops from the rope
and continues along above a narrow
Street bounding from one object to the
next high above the ground
he reaches a platform and drops down
into a shady Courtyard where he calmly
strolls through a door
a subtitle appears as he clasps falad's
hands alhamdulillah praise be to God
alhamdulillah
turned toward Roshan who nods I am glad
you're safe another man walks over to
them
alhamdulillah a first of many
achievements to combust him we should
only hope
there's still much work to do bassim
pulls back his hood and joins Roshan by
a map while our Focus was
full of quietly escouted the city for
where we could erect more bureaus I have
fun dwellings in three districts that
are most unassuming
and Rebecca have arrived from alamut and
set off to al-abasiya and karch I will
make my way to sharkia shortly and I
will join Rebecca in Carr
where corruption is as common as the
irid heir
see Abu Jafar about some things he's
been working on then come find us Roshan
and fulan step away while bus him joins
Abu at a table have a look Blossom I may
have something that is of interest to
you a diagram appears showing an
assortment of tools in a circle
a blow dart is selected and the words
unlock blow dart appear resourceful as
always my thanks abujafar Basim turns
from Abu and strides to a notice board
a diagram showing several missions
appears and one labeled the concubine is
selected
text below the assignment reads one of
calip's concubines a Rebel Spy was
brought to the prince's Palace for
interrogation assassinate whoever is
holding her captive
now time passes quickly as Waseem sits
outside wearing a pensive look then
purchase above a building's Dome an
eagle soaring by near him
later he rises from the bench and Bounds
up to a rooftop where he steps out onto
the horizontal beam that juts out above
a bustling Street
this is the
what do you see in kidu the evil in keto
Dodges an arrow
let us reconsider the approach text
weeds and keto is fleeing due to a
marksman in the area
[Music]
Dives and soars down to land on a cart
full of hay before rising and sprinting
over to the walls of the palace
he quickly scales up a wall
the view of the area Beyond briefly goes
dark and text reads restricted area of
Princess Palace bus him leaps and lands
in a flower bed near some civilian women
act as usual a girl who likes me said
she and Ali's followers are trying to
overthrow the prince what Madness they
will surely fail after a figure labeled
assassinate walks past the group Basim
steps away from the women in crouching
creeps stealthily around a wall and
through some plants the tool choices
appear again and blow dart is selected
hits one of two guards with a dart
[Music]
s
as the unheard guard goes to his comrade
side Basim stabs him then continues
onwards
he makes his way past a large pile of
bulging sacks then creeps through
another flower bed
the tool choices reappear and noise
maker is selected
[Music]
Basim throws the noisemaker behind a
guard and it explodes
what Basim sneaks up behind the
distracted guard kicks his legs out then
stabs him
die now spotting another guard ahead but
seem hurls a blade and takes him down
dashing past his victims Basim climbs an
outdoor staircase
he swiftly scales up the side of a tower
to where an Archer stands
blessing stabs him and hurls him off the
tower the sky is safe my friend
survey the area in kidu text reads
Marksman eliminated and kidu is
available there is my target
the eagle soars above an ornate building
now Basim deftly tight ropes across a
line running from the tower to his
Target building
he climbs up the structure's wall and
drops to a rope stretching over a
courtyard
The View dims and bus him peers down at
a man labeled assassinate who hits the
prisoner
three guards stand on a balcony that
partly encircles the courtyard
the ghostly shape of Basim appears
beside each of the guards
the same is transported to each of the
three spots one after the other where he
quickly dispatches each of the Three Men
and no more need die this day
moving higher as Basim peers down at the
interrogation the tool chosen is trap
shifting a Target across the floor of
the courtyard Basim picks the spot and
hurls the trap which sinks into the
ground
he leaps from the balcony railing and
seen in slow motion lands on the
interrogator and kills him
Wasim draws a sword and slices an
attacker his trap explodes in Green
Smoke dropping another man Pumba scene
dashes past
oh he nears two others
red smoke erupts Simba seems awake
after scampering back over the palace
walls vasim drops down on a man and
delivers him a fatal blow
he trots off down a narrow Street and
through an outdoor Marketplace
[Music]
to take in the dome
tops of the sprawling City Awash in
Golden sunlight as in kidu soars past
the tower
an ornate a-shaped logo appears above
the words Assassin's Creed Mirage
text appears around more game footage
discover the deluxe edition a Ubisoft
original Assassin's Creed Mirage October
12th pre-order available now